あのただ思想的に哲学的に一切皆空
すべてのものは空であるという風に
この仏論理を持っていくんではなくて
実践的に仏教では初期仏教では空という風に見ていたんですからね
そこら辺で この大乗仏教の空の思想と
そして初期時代の空の思想というのは
一応同じものではありません
そこで基本的な思考のパターンはこの前説明しましたし
今日からは別に難しくない同じパターンの仏教では
それでどんどん進んでいくと思います
プ
ヌチャ・パラング・アーナンダ・ビクク・アマナシ・カリットワ・マヌッサ・サンニャン・アマナシ・カリットワ・アランニャ・サンニャン・パタウィ・サンニャン・
パティッチャ・マナシ・カロティ・エーカッタ・タッサ・パタウィ・サンニャーヤ・チッタ・パッカンダティ・パシーダティ・サンティッタティ・ヴィムッチャティ・
セイヤターピ・アーナンダ・ウサバチャッマン・サングサ・テーナ・スリハタン・ティガタ・ワシカン・エーワ・メーワコ・アーナンダ・ビクク・ヤン・イミッサ・パ
タウィヤ・ウックーラ・ウィクールカン・ナビ・ウィドゥッカン・カーヌ・カンタッカ・カーヌ・カンタッカ・ダーラン・パッバタ・ウィサマン・タン・サッバン・アマ
ナシ・カリットワ・パタウィ・サンニャン・パティッチャ・マナシ・カロティ・エーカッタ・タッサ・
パタウィ・サンニャーヤ・チッタ・パッカンダティ・パシーダティ・サンティッタティ・ヴィムッチャティ
そこでシュンヤをシュンヤという空というものはどのように見ますか？ということは
あの 前の説明で言ったのは
このアランニャサンニャンということを観察するんだと
アランニャっていうのは空き地という意味で訳しましたけど
おそらくそれわかっているならばいいんですけど
アランニャってのは空き地で
空き地っていうことに集中してみると
そうすると心はそれに集中する
そうすると その人にとっては心は落ち着いています
多数の複数のものは認識してないんです
ただ認識しているのは空き地
それだけ認識している
それだけ知っている 他のものは知らないことになる
で それで心は落ち着いてきますね
そうすると 普通だったら土地といえば建物があって
いろんなもの 人々がいて
動物がいて 大変複雑性なんですね
木があって 花が咲いてとかね
そういうもの いろんなものを見ると
見ると見ると あれもある
これもある これもある
それもあるということになってしまっちゃうんですね
そうすると みるみるものに過ぎて心は回転するんですね
で それでこのもう結構落ち着きがなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この修行する場合は
このあるものを壊すんではなくて
こちらでいろいろ花が咲いてますけど
だから綺麗で大変素晴らしいとかなんとか思っちゃうと
心がそこに行って動揺しますね
それであって あるいはその花が咲いてますけど
あまり整理していないんではないかと
ですから ここの枝を切って
ここら辺の余分な花を切って
色をなんとかした方がいいんじゃないか
そういうふうに思ったりしちゃうと
それなりに心動揺したりしますね
それで物があると認識したんだから心が動揺しますから
故にそのものを壊しちゃえばいいんじゃないかという話は話になりません
それでそうやって複雑その建物を街
店と人々 動物とか そういう様々なものは認識しないで
空き地という空き地という何もないところを認識する
で 空き地という感覚で
その認識で集中力が生まれたら
まあその認識で街にでも入ってもいることはできますよ
街にいろいろ街にいろいろ建物などがあるかもしれませんだけど
本人にとっては空地を見るように見ているような感覚でいようと思えばいられるんですね
だからその分 心は動揺しないし
落ち着いているし で それで心にとってはこの複雑な建物やら店やら人々やら動物やら
自分の心は認識しないんですからね
そこからシューニャになるんだと
シューニャ 空っぽになるんだと
その認識で心がきれいになって
空っぽになる だからこちらで見ている見方っていうのは
自分 私が見ているこの牛が空ですか
そうではないかという問題ではないんです
牛は本来は空ですよとか言ったっても
それは単なる思考で考えることであって
それでもって何かなるかということではありません
自分の思考だからそれで解脱になるわけでもないし
自分が牛は空ですよと言ったって
もう一人の人は違いますよという可能性もある
それは単なる見方のことで
そういう不穏な見方はしているわけじゃないんですね
その代わりに牛を認識しないことにする
と 牛を認識しないことにすれば
牛について空ですか あるいは有ですかとかね
無ですか 有ですか あるかないかとか
それはどうでもいいことになってしまっちゃうんですね
関係ないことになってしまっちゃうんですね
それで心はその点で落ち着くと
自分の心にとっては それで牛ということからは空というサンニャーが
空というサンニャーは何か訳しましたけど
昨日サンニャーについてもう一回言葉言いましたけど
うんうん そうですね そういうあの
その牛がいるという概念
その現象というのは自分の心にはない
それでシューニャということになるんですね
だからシューニャということは
ブッダに続いては一つ心の状態であって
物理学的にシューニャがないかとか
そういうふうに外の世界じるものではないんですね
外の世界はもうシューニャであろうか
空であろうか 実体であろうと取っておきなさいということになっちゃうんですね
その思考の同じパターンで
どんどん心をさらに育てていくんですね
だから 1番目のセットは説明を多くしましたから
1番目のセットでは まあ空地を観察するとね
山があるんだ 森があるんだとかね
いろんな植物があるんだという煩わしい概念は心にない
でもある点ではちょっと煩わしいんですね
アランニャ 空に空き地があるんだという空き地を認識しているんだから
それ空き地を認識している空き地という対象からは
心はいくらか概念で回転しているんですね
だからそこら辺ではちょっとまだまだちょっと問題があるですけど
ものすごい多数の現象はもう取ってないんだからね
ものすごく心は落ち着いています
で 今日はアマニシカリットア マヌスサンニャン アマニシカリットア アランニャサンニャン
そこで今日はこのアマニシカリットア 観察しないでマヌスサンニャン人間がいるんだという
その概念 その現象は取りません
認識しない アマニシカリットア アランニャサンニャン
それからもうこれは空き地ですよと
それを認識しない これやろうとすれば
例えばここら辺にしても
幡ヶ谷のここら辺は全然空き地でも何でもない
たくさんの人々が住んでいる
でもその心育てて これ全部この何て言いますか
抜けた抜けちゃう 様々な概念を心から抜けてもらって
空き地を認識する ここら辺にある
そういうやり方でもやれますけどね
で なんかバカでかい建物というのはすごい建物ではないかと思っちゃうと
心は動揺する そうではなくて
建物はもう削除して その空き地を認識する
ここら辺 これぐらいの時ですよ
だから東京の中って もうすごい簡単にできますよ
だから私も時々遊びでやったことありますけど
ものすごいもう驚くほどの建物があったりして
空き地を認識したらこれがちっぽけなことじゃないですか
だからそれを認識してみると
もうまあそこで別にもうどうったことはないってことになっちゃうんです
だから自分にとってはもう誘惑される
誘惑されるってことはまるっきりないんですね
全くなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この そういうやり方なんですね
だからわざと空き地へ行って空き地を認識するということでもないんです
それはちょっとした心の訓練なんです
認識しないということでね
受け取らないということ
だから電車に乗っても人がいっぱいということになると
人を認識すると一人一人の人間が違うんですね
一人一人の人間の服装が違う
歩き方 座り方 喋り方 手振り身振りのこと
すべて各人が違う それを一つ一つ完成と思っちゃいます
すごくもうもうもうできるわけじゃないし
それに自分の好みが入り込んじゃうんだから
かなり苦しくなっちゃうんだ
だから電車に乗ったら
もう電車は空っぽの車両を認識してみる
人は全部もうコンピューターだったら簡単にできますから
写真なんかはね 今必要なものを残しておいて
いらんものは全部取ってもらうとね
そんな感じでやるんですよ
電車に乗ったら 車両の中の空きの車両を認識してみる
そうすると もう車両だなと思ったら
ただずっと並んでて かなり長いし
もうずっと座席が両側並んであって
もうそれ側があったりして
で もう結構気持ちいい雰囲気になるんです
だから人がいてもいること関係ないんで
その雰囲気さえ自分で作れば
だからわざとお金払って
一つその車両を特別に注文することができますね
どんな電車でもね 何て言いますか
あれは貸切に貸し切りにして
自分でもう一人だけ乗って
ある決まってる日から決まってる駅まで行く
それはあまり心の育て方にはなりませんね
まあそれすごいお金もかかるし
いつでもできるわけじゃないしね
でもまるっきり人を誰も車両を認識して
気持ちよく 穏やかな気持ちで行きたいところに行きたいと思えば
その心の訓練があれば何のこともないんですよ
いつでもどんな電車に乗ってでも
その気持ちでいられることはできますね
すごい気持ちよくて こんなに大きな車両ではないかと簡単にいられます
それはすごい気持ちいいことなんですよ
だからその人がそちらも人がある
こちらも人がいる こちらも人がいると
そういう認識しちゃうと
すごく狭くなって また心がすごくもう煩わしい状態になってくる
認識しないことになっちゃうと
もうまたそこら辺で心が落ち着いてくる
でもそれもいいんだけど
空っぽの車両を認識してるんだから
この車両から出てくる情報にとっては
ほんの僅かに心はまた煩わしい状態にはなります
だから車両にしたっても
それなりの構成というか
そういうものがあって
座席のデザインというものがあったりしてね
床の色というものがあったりして
それはもう各車両は違いますしね
各車両とやっても あの
各 あの 線によって違うしね
時々同じ線であろうとも
中のデザインが違う場合もあるしね
それで床はもうちょっと使いすぎて古ぼけているんだったらね
その分は心は反応するんですよ
まあ時々一生懸命磨いていることは分かりますけど
磨いたことになってない床もあります
で だからまあそこら辺認識しちゃうと
そこら辺をこれまた動揺させたりはします
例えばこの東京の方の道路とかね
あの みんな狭く感じるんだけど
かなりバカでかいんですよ
渡れませんだから この
渡るともう赤信号に変わってるんだからね
それぐらい幅が広いんですよ
で だから でも全然感じません
例えば東京駅を降りて
あの前の道路を渡ろうと思ったら
結構もう待っていて 待ってて
また信号変わってもいくらか走っていかないと向こうまで行けないぐらい
かなり幅広い道路ばっかりありますね
もう誰も まあこんなに広々した道路あるんじゃないかって
その雰囲気感じたことはないと思いますね
ですから そこら辺見たら
ああ 東京の道路ってのは狭くてしょうがないって
そういう文句じゃなくて
車と人を全部消してみて下さい
どれぐらい広いかと そうすると
この広さっていうのは味わって
心を楽しみでいられますね
だからそれが修行の実践になっちゃうんですね
だからあるあると思うんじゃなくて
それはもうないないとも思うんじゃなくて
まあもう認識しないことにする
これを認識する 選ぶんですね
何を見て何を見ないことにするかと
ですから それは馬鹿げたことでもないんです
あくまでも能力の問題なんです
例えばこの絨毯を見て
じゃあ赤だけ見ましょうということは馬鹿げた話ではないんですよ
そんなものを子供たちにもさせますから
それは区別判断能力に必要なものだからね
だから同じ絵を 2つ見せてね
間違い探してくださいと
全く同じ絵なんですけど A
とBと比べるとどこか 1つの場所が間違っているんだよと
そうすると そのA 2つ比べる人が
ある 1つに集中するんですね A
と似ていないところはどこかというふうに
[背景音楽]だからそれも同じ能力なんですね
だからそれに沿われてみて
あの畳覧を見て まあ全部ガチャガチャ絵やら絵柄やら鳥やら色々ありますけど
それは何らかんでも見るんじゃなくて
じゃあ赤だけ見ようかなと
じゃあこの畳覧に像の絵もありますけど
じゃあ像だけ見ようかなとかね
というと まあまあまあこれぐらいここら辺の像がいるんだぞと
それだけに 終わります
そこでそのやり方で番目に行きますね
番目にはこの人々いるんだっていうことはもう認識しないことにする
それから空き地だよということも認識しないことにする
パタウィサンニャン パタウィだよと
パタウィっていうのはもう土ということなんですね
そうするとすごい単純になっちゃう
まあ土 土地ぐらいでもよろしいんですね
だからグラウンド ランド
土地 あるいはパタウィっていう風な
まあ土 まあそういう風にどちらにとってもよろしいんですね
例えば空き地でもいろんなこの葦やら
いろんなもうね 草やらね
葉っぱがありますね それ認識しない
そうすると あの葦だけの空き地でしたっても
葦もそれぞれ一つ一つ別々別々で個人的なもうもうもう個性持っているんだから
そんなこと見ようとちゃうと
もう切りがなくなっちゃいますね
だからではなくて 下は全部同じ色の土ではないかと
土地ではない そうやって土というものに
土地あるいはもうもう土ですね
どちらかに認識してみて
それに集中 集中する だから一つしか認識しないということで
そこでどんどんどんどん他のことには興味がなく
ただ土だということを上手に心に移ってくるんですね
それで喩えがありまして
まあ喩えは私は訳しなくてもいいと思いますけど
どうでしたっけ  牛の皮が百本のくさびでよく打ったらしわが消えるようなものです
例えば その場合 理屈はこの地における上り坂や下り坂
川や難所 切り株やトゲのある場所
山や崖という そのすべてを視視して
地の層によって一生を視する
うーん こちらの土の喩えは
例えばなんだよね 雄牛ですかね
うん その牛の皮が本の
百本  百本 何ですか？ くさびって釘のようなものですね
太鼓やなんか作る時に皮を引っ張ってこう押さえる
打たれ えーと しわですか？ はい
しわです  しわが消えるようなものですと
ちょうどそのようになんだよとかね
だからこの まあ牛の皮はもうかなり毛があって
しわしわあっていろいろありますけど
それはもう綺麗に磨いて
もう釘を打って伸ばしておく
で どうせ皮を調整する場合は釘を打っておくんですね
昔も今も もうギューギューと伸ばして釘を打って
また伸ばして釘を打って
またそのまま放っておくんですね
しっかりするまで そうすると牛という感じもないし
もう何もなく ただ真っ平で
もうこれしか認識できないんですね
もうあの外見全部消えてるんですね
そのようにだよということが
土はどのように見るべきかということなんです
だから土はもうこうやってガタガタで
もうもう小さな塊があって
もうもうちょっと穴があったりとかね
そういう風に観察するんじゃなくて
真っ平らの土という感じで
で その考えで見てみるんですね
だから心にはそういう風にどんどんサマーディというかね
集中してくると そういう風に映ってくるんです
心を安定していると このすごく真っ平らで
ただ土だけずっと どこどこを見てもただの土という土地という薄く取るんだ
まあこのそのように見るんだろうと
そこで で 次にエアメール
コーアナンだ 比丘ヤンイニッサパタリアウククウラビクウラカンナディビドゥカン
そこで普通の土だったら色々ものありますね
何でしたっけ？上がり坂や下り坂とね
川や  難所 難しいところ
それから切り株やいばらですね
棘のトゲトゲした場所
それから山や崖といういろんな側面がある
普通の そういうものは恣意せず
そんなものは取りません
認識しません ただ 地という層によって一生を恣意しますと
地のその層によって 一つの側面をそれだけを認識するってことですか？ だから真っ平らの土だけ認識
認識する  他のものは全部取らないことにする
まあわざと平らにするんです
まあこちら側は上り坂ありますよと思ったら
また心その辺で多様性を認識しますからね
そこで区別世界が成り立っちゃいますね
だから上り坂でももう上がり坂でも
ちょっと難所でも それは全然気にしないで
すっごい綺麗な平らとして認識する
そう エヴァンパジャナでヤンガスダレタマヌスサンニャンパティッチェーデナッティ
そうやって平らの土 土地
そういうふうに認識しちゃう
そうできたところで彼がこういうことをしますね
知ってます ヤンガスダレタマヌスサンニャンパティッチェ
人間がいるんだということで
なんか何か疲れが何か煩わしい
ダレタっていうのは疲れっていうことなんですけど
煩わしい状態ですね あったならばそれは今ない
ジェアスダレタアランニャサンニャンパティッチェーデナッティ
まあただ空き地ですよとかね
森ですよという認識で
何か心に煩わしい状態があったならば
それももうないと アッティチェアヤンダレタマッタ
でもほんのわずかに一つ疲れがもう煩わしい状態があります
ダレタマッタ ヤディダンパティヴィサンニャンパティッチェエーカッタ
ただ土地だ 土だというその認識で
心はまだちょっと動揺してはいるんですね
でも人間がいるんだ 建物があるんだ
崖があるんだ もう何もない
心には それで心はかなり落ち着いてますけど
またわずかにパティサンハっていうことで
動揺的な状態はありますと
そう スンニャン・イダン・サンニャガタン・マヌッサ・サンニャーイイティ・パジャナーティ
彼がスンニャン・イマン・サンニャーガタン
このサンニャー自体がスンニャだよとわかってるんですよ
サンニャーっていうのは自分の認識だから
思考 自分の持ってる認識
概念だから だから今この体にあるこの認識概念の中では
もう人間という認識はありません
もうスンニャない 存在しない
ヤマヤマという認識はもうない
存在しないと で スンニャン・イダン・サンニャーガタン・アランニャ・サンニャン
森だ 空き地だという概念からももうない
だから確実にスンニャ
空性は 空性は自分のサンニャーにおいては成り立ってます
だから世の中空にしてやろうではなくて
世の中あるかないかっていうのは自分の認識次第だから
自分の認識の中にはない
もう存在しないということで
だからずっとあるという認識で生きていたんだから
だから認識っていうのはいつでもあるということで認識するんですね
そこら辺はもう何回も私は講演
解説 法会では説明しましたけどもね
まあまあ あんまり一般的な仏教の世界ではね
そこら辺は言えません
もう人間には理解できませんしね
だからまあ 理解できるぐらいの人ってあんまり出そうもしませんだからね
まあできない人に限って聞くんですよ
だからそれすごく困りますけどね
まあとにかくそれでもまあ理解はしないだろうとは知った上で
とにかく説明したんですよ
ものがあると認識するんです
ないとは認識しないんです
まあそれ単純に考えてください
例えばこちらで花があると花を認識するんであって
花がない花がないと認識不可能なんです
こちら花がなかったらもう壁があるとかね
絨毯があるとかに そういうふうに認識が動いているんです
だから認識っていうのはあるということなんです
実体があるということなんです
で ないということは 認識することは論理的にはまた意味もないんですよ
例えばこの部屋に何がないかと聞いたっても切りがありますかね
何でも言えるんだから
この部屋には新幹線がないと
電車がないと 車はないとかね
ゾウもトラも動物もいないと
ちょっと待て 魚もいないとかね
そういう風にないないとは言えるんだけど
それはないという認識ではありません
それさえも だからこちらがもう魚もこの部屋には魚もいませんと言っても
その人は他のどこかにいる魚を認識して
その魚はこの部屋にあるものと比べるとないと言ってるだけのことなんです
だから私たちはただ じゃあこの部屋にないもののないものを認識しましょうと思ったっても
何かあるものを認識しようとしちゃちゃうんですね
ですから 普通はもう部屋に入ったら何があるかと認識する
街に行ったら何があるかと認識する
だから認識自体があるということなんです
だから いくら認識で思考で踏ん張っても
解脱の世界とはまるっきり関係ないんです
認識するということは
実在論的であって有の世界なんですね
だから例えば仏教はもう理解してやるぞといくら踏ん張っても
それはもう仏教の教えと涅槃というのは理解できるわけじゃないんです
だからブッダが語っている世俗的なところは
もう認識でき 理解できます
出世間の境地っていうのは全く認識はできます
だから認識がないんだから
そこら辺では 認識っていうのはものがあるというところで認識だからね
だから仏教っていうのはあるということは成り立たないんだからね
ものは無常ですから あるということでは成り立ち成り立ちませんね
だからまあ瞬間のことだから
だからあったとは言えますけどね
花火はあったと 花火はあるとは言えませんよ
ある時間の瞬間で花火がもう
出てきてもう消えたという
その瞬間で花火はあったということは言えます
だから大体我々の認識というのは
その過去の出来事を認識しています
今も我々は見ているんだけど
過去なんですよ 見ているんです
聞いてるんだけど それも過去なんです
だからそれは だからこの仏教の時間論というのは
もうものすごい速い瞬間をとってますから
心がね すごい速く変化していますからね
だから起きた出来事を認識しているんですね
だからそれもあると思って勘違いもするし
だからそこら辺の大変な複雑な問題がありますね
簡単には解決できません
修行するしか方法はないんですね
心を集中してみるしか
他の手段はないんですね
そうとあるいかすることっていうのは
ですから 認識するということがあるということで
相が生まれた 概念が生まれたということは
自分にとってはあるというふうに勘違いしてしまったということなんですね
それで じゃあ空はどのように認識するべきかと
言うと お釈迦様は厳密に実践的に語っているんです
このやり方だよと だからそれはもう大乗で老中たちが言っている空想よりはもうはるかに優れているんです
だから厳密に心の認識過程というのを知った上で
こういうふうにしたらどうでしょうかと
だから この複層にこのあると思っているものは
もうちょっと工夫して
これをないことにして
他の何かあるということにする
そうやって置き換えていくんですね
その時もアランヤ・アキチという認識が本当にあるんですよ
それで複層のいろんなものあるという認識が消えてしまったんですね
今は土ということにする
土だけ認識する時の瞑想は必ず必要なんです
なぜ平らで認識するんだからね
平らでもう真っ平で この引いた皮のようにね
太鼓の皮のように真っ平にして
土のみを認識するためには結構集中力は必要でしょうしね
それでその人にはこの真っ平になったこの土があるという認識があります
でも他の認識は何一つもない
それで自分の認識の内容を見てみると
かなりショーニャが成り立っているんです
どんなショーニャ・空性が生が成り立っているかというと
人間がいるんだ 山があるんだとかね
川があるんだとかね そういうものは認識の内容には存在しない
それで空性が成り立っていると
でも一つはややこしいものがある
土という 相が その概念が認識としてある
これはどうにもならない
認識してないんだからね
生きているんだから認識しているんですよ
だからある一つあるものとして捕まってはいる
土という一つの概念は空じゃないんですね
それは 他のものはもう空性になってしまってるんだけど
それだけはもう認識として空性としてではないものとして残ってるんですね
それでアッティチェーライダンアスンヤタン
アスンヤタ これは不空性
不空性ですね 空性なんで
この一つだけは不空なんで空でありません
それは何なのかというと
パタウィサンガンですね
ヤリダンパタウィサンガンパティッチャーダ
たった一つパタウィ 土があるんだということはまだ残っていると
イティヤンヒコタッテネホーティテーナタンスンヤンサマノパッセティ
そこでイティヤンヒコタッテネホーティ
何か何かそこにないならば
それについてスンヤと言えるでしょうと
テーナタンスンヤンサマノパッセティ
心はスンヤになりましたと
空性になりましたと どういう風にと
山やら人間やらね 森やら
そういう風な思考から空性になったんだぞということになりますね
そんなものを考えちゃうと
また概念で考えることをしません
だからそこら辺は理解してほしい
その修行する人が土だけ認識して
土だという認識でいる
それすごい心は穏やかになっている
それでその人はまた哲学的に
故に私の心にはもう空性ですよと
山が存在しない 考えちゃうとまた普通の世界に戻りますからね
そんなことするわけじゃないんです
こちらはその状況を説明する
説明すると あくまでも普通の世界の話で
俗世間の話になるんですね
説明は俗世間の説明で
論理的な世界で 哲学的な世界で
そんな大したことじゃないんです
だからこちらでお釈迦様はただ俗世間の次元にまた戻って
論理的なこのコースを説明する
だからその人の場合はイティヤンヒコタッテネホーティ
その認識において 何が何がないかということについては
空性であると認識するんだそうと
ヤンパナタッテアウィサッタンホーティ
タッタサンタンイダンアッティーティパジャナンティ
それから自分の心に何がまだまだ抜けてないもの
削除できなかったものがあるんだったら
それについては不空性やと知ってるんだと
いわゆる土があるんだというふうな状態でいる
だから土があるんだ ただそれで止まってるんです
何がないんでしょうかと
またそれも認識しません
それはもう本当は不可能ですからね
何がないかなと思っちゃう
またあるものをまた認識しなくちゃいけないんだからね
それをやりません だからこの部屋で何がないかなと皆様に聞いたっても
それで空性は成り立つわけじゃないんです
ありったけの世の中にあるものを何でも言えばいいんだから
逆にそれまた逆効果なんですね
結局 部屋にあるものだけ観察しちゃうと
物は少ないんだから落ち着いていられるのに
じゃあないものを観察しなさいと言っちゃうと
もう死んじゃいますよ
精神的には だって何でも想像できますから
じゃあ例えば 例えばニューヨークの街を想像して
この部屋にはあれもない
これもないと言えばね
ニューヨーク街を想像しただけでも
もうもうかなり腹が立つほどいろんなものあるんだから
ある人がパリを想像するとかね
だから何でも想像できますよ
そういうことだから ないものを認識しろという方法では
もう実践的ではありません
やっぱりあるものの中で認識しないことにして
一つだけ認識するということね
だからこの絨毯を見ると
じゃあ赤だけ認識してみようとかね
じゃあ白色だけ認識してみようかとかね
そういう風にしてみるんですね
例えば絨毯を見て赤だけ認識していって
どんどんどんどん心を集中していくと
赤しか見えないようになっちゃう
そうすると絨毯は全部真っ赤になってくるんです
自分にとっては そうすると
この鳥の絵柄やら像の絵やらね
いろいろ見て 花やらね
そうやって心に映る複雑な状態が消えてしまっちゃって
赤のみを認識することができるようになる
タッタサンタンイダンアッティーティパジャナンティ
エヴァンピッサエーサアーナンダヤタハブッダアウィパッラッタパリッスッダハスンヤッタワッカンティバヴァティ
コノーヨーニャーナンダヤタハブッダ
ありのままに如実に 正しくアウィパッラッタ
心は変動しないで逆さまにならないで
いわゆる勘違いしないで
ありのままに見る場合は
パリッスッダ またすごい清らかなスンニャターヴァッカン
空性が空性というこの空であるということは
そういうふうに心に入ってくるんだと
だから空性は無性だからね
本当は 論理的に言えば
空性イコール無性なんですね
だから無性たるものは
漢字は知ってますね 空性というのは性質の性で空であること
無性っていうのは無であることですよ
だから空性というのは無性ですから
無性はまあ認識できるかと
そんな簡単には認識できません
認識っていうのは有性を認識するためにできているもんなんですね
有を認識するためにできているものであって
無は認識しません それでそれも何なのかというと
これはものすごい物理学的なことで
耳に音という物質がバンバン耳の鼓膜にぶん殴っちゃうと
神経が起きてきて電気を起こしちゃって聴覚を作るんですよ
網膜じゃない 鼓膜？網膜？鼓膜
だから鼓膜に何もぶつけてこないと聴覚は生まれてきませんよ
それでこれも全部素粒子だから重いんですよ
光もかなり重いんです
ですから 瞑想して結構我々すごい敏感になってみると
光って結構重いんだなとわかると思いますよ
だからこうやって光が当たると
皮膚までかなり重さがあるんです
光が消えた瞬間でさっと軽くなっちゃうんですよ
ですから 物質がきちんと目にボンボンと触れない限りは
例えば格子が目に触れて目を押さえない限りは起きてこないんですね
ですから 認識 起きたっていうことを認識しないんですよ
あるんだ だから認識があるということなんですね
だから世の中ではブッダの教え以外
すべての哲学はうろんなんです
空論はないんです 一番面白い例っていうのは大乗仏教の空論なんです
あれは正真正銘のうろんなんですよ
空性っていうのはあって
実体であるというところまで発展しちゃったんです
空っていうのは何もないわけではありませんと
現代のものすごく偉そうに言う
この間もどこかの禅の寺に行ったんだからね
そこで若坊主がすっごく偉そうに
空っていうのは何もないっていう意味ではありませんとかね
だからもうまあまあ青いもいいところと思ったんだけど
まあ住職だからどうにもならんしね
そういう立場でね 人を抑えるんですけどね
私には何の立場もないんですけど
まあ黙っていたんですけど
本当にもう何も わかってないガキでしょうとということでいたんですけど
やっぱりかっこよく言葉では遊んでるんですね
誰かがおじさんがね まあ全てなんとかもうまあ大丈夫
教義を勉強して 全て物証とかね
全部同じ何か実体として
一つそのものとして 私は見て
それはすごくありがたい教えですよと
で いたら まあ禅の場合はそうも言わないんだからね
カップはカップで空であるとかね
なんとかくだらんこと言ってますからね
だからまあまあそこら辺に行っちゃいますからね
私はあのおじさんの思考はね
まあちょっとやばいと思って
まあ壊しちゃったら その人にとってはもう大変土台が崩れちゃってね
もう生きていられなくなっちゃうし
だから ある一つの絶対的な妄想で
それで生きているんだからね
それはいきなり壊せませんよ
ゆっくりと まあだから無我っていうのはいきなりゴーンと語れるものじゃないんです
もう精神的にもうイカれてしまうんですよ
だから あるお坊さんがお釈迦様に我ですか？無我ですか？と
言ったら黙っていたんです
またまたもうしつこく聞くと
それで ああ そう あなたしつこく聞くんですかと
じゃあ 説明しても 説明したところで
ものすごく落ち込んじゃって
もう頭がものすごく混乱して
もう狂った状態に陥ったんです
それでお釈迦様はもうだからお釈迦ものたちにね
そんな話聞いたってわからないんだと
今まで私に我がありましたと
これがもうお釈迦様はもうないというんだから
もうなくなっちゃったと
いうふうに勘違いするんだと
だからそこら辺はそういう
そんな簡単ではありません
仏教の無常論 無我論 無空論というのはね
で 我々お釈迦様のこの悟りの教え以外
家の中にある一切の教え
思考っていうのはもう誤論であります
それもはっきりしています
そこで論理的に空というものを成り立たそうと頑張ると
それはあくまでも思考の遊びだから愚論なんです
まあですから 例えば唯物相対的な思考を持っていて
まあ論理的に存在しないというね
あるのはもう相対性のみというふうにね
言ってはいるんですが
それで空を認識するかというと認識しません
空そのものの認識で終わるんです
だから彼らにとってはもう実践ということはないんだからね
頭で遊んで ある思考を置き換えて別な思考を埋め込んでもらう
それだけのことで だから別な思考を埋め込んでもらったら
その思考自体が有性なんですよ
空性じゃないんですね
それがなんで気をつけないかとね
唯物は 色自体が有性であるということは
なんで気にしないかと
だからこの まあ無責任でね
あれもこう これもこうやってと言ってもね
だからこの法華信行という経典を見ると
そこら辺はわかりますね
もうなんだかんだも空と空と言いながら
徹底的な実体論であの短い経典が終わっちゃうんですね
最後になってくると まあこれこそもう
ギャーギャーギャーギャーとか何とかって言ってね
あれ何やと だからまあこれ自体はすごい力のある呪文やと
なんとか言いながらね
だから空であるということは
徹底絶対的な実体にしてしまうんです
四聖諦はない 因果法則はない
輪廻はない 涅槃もない
えらいこと言っちゃったぞと
だからこれ自体が絶対的なというふうに
あの言葉に引っかかって
そこでもう絶対的な愚論で
まあ有性で終わっちゃうんですね
だから じゃあ法華信行を実践して悟った人は一人いるかと
唱えるもんでしょ あれは
御利益のために写経するもんでしょ
それですごい超能力というか
神秘能力あるんだから大事に大事にするものでしょうに
別にあれで心穏やかにするために
心の煩悩なくすためのなんてもないんですよ
だからいろんな宗教でいろんなおもちゃで遊んでるでしょ
同じ まあそちらは法華信行でというおもちゃで遊んでいるんですね
マギスト教だったら十字架で遊んでいるんだからさ
もっと無茶が必要なんですね
だからもう体にこうやって十字架の印それだけでも神回ってくれるとかね
で そんな風にも で 何かね
もう神が降りると 神の霊が降りると思ってね
水を飲んだり なんとか食べたりとかね
いろいろもうおもちゃ作って遊んでるんでしょうし
イスラムの人々にもそれでいろいろおもちゃがあるんですね
とにかくおもちゃが必要っていうことでね
それでおもちゃ遊びやってるんであって
これは空について語っている話にすると
結局おもちゃになっているんですけどね
だからこの そういう風な
この生半可なことではないんですね
これはもう厳密に心の認識の問題であって
どのように空性というものに迫っていくかというね
空性と取っちゃうと それはどうしても有性になっちゃうんですね
だから空性についての瞑想っていうのはないんです
で それ自体危険だから
何がないかと認識しちゃうと
もうすべての有を認識しなくちゃあかんだからね
だからこれしか方法はないっていうことなんです
イコール対象だから空は対象がない
なんでそういうふうに思ったんですか
頭の中でそう覚えたわけですね
このパタビの  だからパタビがあるということは有性でしょう
うん だから有でしか認識できませんだから
いろんな複数の有性をやめて一つにしてみる
一側面に対象を絞るっていうこと
そうするとそちらには課題の量の空性は成り立ってるんです
実際にその心の中に  例えばいいですか
ちょっとバカな話かもしれませんが
百パーセント空性の中の一つだけパタビがあったら
それが仮に二十パーセントとしたら
八十パーセントは空性というふうに言えませんか？ 百パーセント
何？ 空性という一つのものが百パーセントの値とするんです
それで今先生がおっしゃったパタビ
カシナですね カシナが一つあるんです
一側面 それはもしその空性全体から占める二十パーセントだとしたら
あとは百から二十引くから八十は空性と言えますかって質問
うんうんうん そういうことです
ありがとうございます
ですが その人は百パーセントパタビという性を認識しているんです
その人にとっては  その人にとっては
現在はパタビを百パーセント認識しているということになります
だからあの八十パーセントの空性はなんならそれ認識しない世界だからね
それ それで本当の空性
計りかけないということ
だからこれはもう空だ
空イコール認識ないってことなんですよ
認識イコール無なんです
この人はパテリー百パーセントにして
もう本物の空を取っているんですが
それは認識不可能 認識不可能なんですけど
空性によってダラタタという煩わしいことはなくなるんですね
楽ですよ それであなた楽じゃないかと
今は 山は認識しない 人間は認識しない
そういうものを認識する出てくるありとあらゆる苦しみがもう生まれてこない
認識作用が消えちゃって
消えちゃったんだから
だから心は平安にはなってます
八十パーセント  私流に言わせていただければ
平安にはなってます で
本人がじゃあ空性認識しようと思っちゃうと
また有性になってしまって
またとんでもないことになってしまいます
それになってると  うん
だから空性を認識しようと思っちゃうと
これはもう有性もいいとこで
もうあまりにもタチが悪いところ
元に戻るじゃなくて あまりにもタチが悪いところになるんです
もう顔隠すかな  だってこういうことでしょ
この部屋にあるものを認識しないと言ったら
みんな困らないでしょうに
じゃあこの部屋にあるものを認識してくださいと
あるもののリストを作ってくださいと言ったら誰も困らないでしょ
では この部屋にないもののリストを作って作ってくださいと言っちゃうと
これ誰にもできませんから
いくら作ったっても足らんでしょうに
じゃあ東京のすべてのものをリストアップするか
じゃあ日本全国の全国全部リストアップするか
地球上全てリストアップするかと
どうせだって足らないんだよ
もっとあるんだから 宇宙まで行かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
だから ないものをやろうと思っちゃうと
これ一番タチが悪いんです
それでこの部屋にあるものを全部リストアップしてくださいっちゃうと
それはいくらかはできます
あるものは でもあんためしち面倒くさいだから一つだけ書いてくださいったら
百パーセント足書きるんです
この部屋にあるものは一つ何でもいいんだから
一つだけ書いてくれと
もっとらいとも楽なんです
だからそこで空性 そのやり方で空性を取るんです
で 同じやり方で次に行きます
プネチェパランアナンダビクアマヌシカリットワアランヤサンニャンアマヌシカリットワパテリサンニャンアカサナンチャヤタナ
サンニャンパティッチェマヌシカロティーカッタ
タッサアカサナンチャヤタナサンニャーチッタンパッカンダティパシッドティサンティットティームッチャティ
で あの これ今日はこのもうすごい瞑想の世界で
あの普通日常の知識とは違います
だからパテリーを認識するということは
ある一つの あのパテリーカシナというものすごい厳密な瞑想なんです
だから土というものだけ認識する
山を認識しません 崖も認識しません
で 難所も認識しません
ただ土 それも認識すると心は大きくになってくるんだから
全く言わずに土っていうものの認識に入っちゃうんです
これはサマーディ瞑想で
色界の四つのサマーディ瞑想のことなんですよ
考えているのは それで無色界の瞑想なんです
次に説明しているのは
そこでその修行者が 今お釈迦様がなさったことなんですけど
アランヤサンニャンという空き地のことも観察しないし
土であるということも観察しない
それもやめる やめて アーカサーナンチャーヤタナという
それはどういうことかというと
今自分が認識した土というところがありますね
土っていうのは空間がなければ成り立たないんですね
そこでその土というところを抜けて
その空間を認識する それはアーカサーナンチャーヤタナということなんです
だから空間そのものっていうのはなかなか認識難しい
例えば宇宙の空間なんか認識やろうと思ったってもできません
空間もやっぱり有で認識するんですよ
例えばこちら だからこのこの本置いておきますね
だからこの本を認識しないで
その空間を認識する ある空間がなければそちらに本がいないんです
だからその空間取るためには
このあるものをちょっと助けになるんですね
だからこの  この場合の助けはパテリ
パテリですね だからパテリ
だからパタヴィで自分の心はどれぐらい広く空間をとっていたかっていうこと
その人の修行の能力次第で
で 大体自分の能力ギリギリまで空間を広く
パタヴィを広く取っちゃいます
で 取って それからまあそのパタヴィを認識しないことにする
パタヴィ見えてるんですね
その人に 認識してるんですけど
次に ではこのパタヴィ認識しない
この空間を認識してみる
だからこれはこの修行もかなり訓練が必要で
だから皆様方は私ができることを言いましたから
電車に何回乗ったら電車の人間をもう全部消してみてください
結構訓練が必要なんです
消して 自分一人で あの
この電車に乗っているんだっていうことに
そういうふうな訓練してみると
このやり方がいくらかいくらか身につくと思います
人のあの 訓練というかね
その訓練して そのテクニックというのはね
身についちゃうと まあまあ一応日常生活の中でも
すごく自分の都合よく生活することはできるんですね
例えばどこかあの あの
こちらに来たとしますね
で まあ七 八人の人がいるとしますね
自分にとってはもうみんなバラバラで
まあまあ特にこちらの場合はもうもうみんなそれぞれ統一性ないっていうところがありますから
あの 別にそれ悪口で言ってるわけじゃなくて
別に私も統一させようとはしていないし
みんなの個人人格 個性っていうのはあるんだからね
それは放っておいてるんですね
それで個性あるのは当たり前なんですけど
日本人に限って個性は嫌がるんですね
私はその矛盾が嫌なんです
みんななんでまとめてないかとかね
なんでみんな同じく動くとかね
そんなありえないんですからね
だから初期仏教の世界は個性は放っておくんです
うるさい人はうるさいままで放っておくし
もう全然何も喋らない人はそのままで放っておくんですね
そこで もうよくうるさくてベチャベチャ喋る人がいて
全く人と喋りたくない性格の人が来ますね
すると その人にとってはちょっと居心地が悪いんですよ
あの人々にとっても あの人はなんでずっと黙っているんだからね
なんか気持ち悪いとか思ったりするね
みんな仏教だから 仲良くワイワイとすればいいんじゃないか
そんな一つにまとめるはずがないんです
でも精神の世界だから
これ瞑想ぐらいあるんだったら
例えばしゃべりたくない人にはね
とても簡単にその人々はいないことにするっていうことはできるんです
だからそれはこの無視するっていうことではないんです
自分の認識の世界で だから心は穏やかなままでいられるんです
一人の人がすごくうるさくて
自分が落ち着いていたいと
まあどうしようかっていうという感じで
私には関係ないと 自分の心を穏やかにしておくことはできます
それはこの認識の運転なんです
[背景音楽]ただ無視するということは失礼なことで
人がいる で 私は無視してやるぞというすごい強烈な認識なんですね
そういうことではなくて
これはもうもう本当にものすごく上手の認識を管理して運転してみるということ
だから 20人もいるんだけど
自分は一人でもう瞑想したいから簡単にできます
こちらに来ると 私は新宿の駅で京王線の降りて
ずっと走って降りてきたんですね
降りてもう 3分あるんです
電車には この 3分どうやって待てるかって
3分って私にとってすごい長い時間なんです
それでこの なんていうのは出口に合わせて立ってますから
こちらに で それでこの 1番目の車両止まるところまで
それでも距離があるんですね
私はそこまで歩く瞑想して帰ると
帰るとちょうど 3分やと
だから 3分ボケーッと待つのはもう嫌な色々なものを認識するんだからね
それでその 3分以内で私は何のことなく歩く瞑想しながら行った
だから歩く瞑想のその間でもベンチに立つ人が座っているわ
他の人は避けていかなくちゃいけないしね
で その何一つは認識しない
それで瞬時にもう全くこのタイル張ってるすごい空き地というかね
頭に入って もう誰一人も全く空き地いないではなくて
なんとなく空き地っていう感じていて
向こう行ってまた戻ってくるとちょうど電車が入りますという看板が出ているんですね
まあそれで私は焦る必要ないとも
看板が出てまた何秒間ありますから
そこまできちんと歩いて立ったところで電車が来たですからね
それからまた空想をやめちゃったんですけどね
ですから それで私はあの人々を無視してやるぞとかね
そういうことじゃないんで
その人々に対しても別に何のこともなくて
いるんだけど 自分が認識しないっていうことで
ゆっくり歩いていく だからもうそんなもう 3分のいないのことなんです
その 3分の以内での結構気持ちいい状態でいられると
だからそれはこの運転の上手下手なことでね
その瞬間で考えたのは
もういろんなあっちこっちみんな走り回ってね
道場を探し回ってるっていうのは
やっぱりそれはまあそれ分は弱いではないか
もう別に東京ドームの中で言ったってね
これはアランヤと森やと思っちゃえば森ではないかと
だからこのこれではなくて
これを認識するそうと置き換えるんですよ
だから空想っていうのはそういう風に成り立つの
だから空想は認識だけど
認識してないんです 私は人々は認識しなかった
ベンチは認識しなかった
いろんな看板があって
それを認識しなかった
バカでかい柱があって
ただまっすぐ歩いて そこで歩く時のタイルだけと足の感覚観測だけ認識したんだから
私にとってはそれはその瞬間でウであって
他のものはもうなんですね
で 人がでもいて 人が人の間を縫うようなシチュエーションにおいてでも
そういう  そうです  あり得るんですか？ うん
別に認識しなきゃそれだけのことでしょうに
でも人が目の前にいるのを避けようと思った時に
人を認識  足が前に出て
はいこちらに行って 例えば運びますでしょ
じゃあ右に避けます 右っていうよりも避けますよ
避けて運びますということ
避けるという心を発生させる時の人を見ているということは
どうぞ考えてください
だからこのコンピューターゲームやる人はもうこのいろいろシューティングゲームやらね
上手の人はもう何も考えてないんですよ
左にも行くし 周りにも周りにもいるし
飛ばしたりもするし 撃ったりもするし
だから何も考えないんだから
そこで楽しい 楽しいってことになってるでしょうね
うん とにかくこの次にこのパタウィというものを認識しないで
空間アーカサーナンチャーヤタナという空性というね
だからショーアーヤタナ
スペースですよ ある 何と言いますか
空間ですよ とにかく だからアーヤタナという言葉をわざと使っているんですね
それを認識する そこで集中力が生まれてきて
禅定も生まれてくる サンティッタでリムッチャティ
そこで心はきちっと一体感になって止まるんですよ
この空間について空間のみ認識する
一体感になっちゃうんです
それでその人は空間しか認識していない
サマーディ状態だからね
サマーディ状態っていうのは
もうそれと自分となんとなく一つになってっていうことでね
で それで彼がソーエワンパジャナーティ
まあそこからお釈迦様のまた俗世間にいるっていうのは説明なんですね
ヤンガスダラタアランニャサンニャンパティッチテーダナッティ
空き地ということを認識するとき
あった煩わしいことは今はないんだと
ヤンガスダラタパタウィサンニャンパティッチ
パタウィ 土だと思った時
何か あの 何と言いますか
煩わしい状態あったならば
それ今はないんだと アッティチアヤンダラタマッタヤリダンアーカサーナンチャーヤタナ
空間があるという煩わしいところはほんのちょっとあるんだよということね
なりますね そこでソーエワンパジャナーティ
スンニャンイマンサンニャーアガタン
自分のサンニャー自体が今の
今あるサンニャーにはアランニャがない
パタウィもないと知ってます
いわゆるアランニャからは空である
パタウィからは空であると知りますとか
それは説明で 瞑想中はそんなことはしません
だから論理的には二〇パーセントにしますよね
だから二〇パーセントの空性であった人は
このパタウィも抜けたところで
その二〇パーセントの中で
またもう空間ということになっちゃいますから
パタウィもガタガタなもんだから
まあもっともう減っちゃって
まあ五パーセント 十パーセントぐらい
どうかするとね もう空間という存在がありましてね
でもその人たちは百パーセントの空間は認識しています
次にもう仏教例えないと思います
で 次にアマニシカリタパタウィサンニャンアマニシカリタアーカサーナンチャーヤタナサンニャン
ヴィンヤーナンチャーヤタナパティッチマニシカロティエーカッタ
そこで次にやっていることはかなり難しい
次のことは で アーカサーを認識することもなんとかできます
すいませんだけど このヴィンヤーの色無辺知っとくところにそれ難しいんですよ
で やり方はまあ説明できますけど
この まあそれは禅定の世界だから
常識の世界で説明できる
禅定の世界でこのパテヴィ
土だけ 全部土やというふうに認識する
すごい気持ちいい状態なんですよ
その遊びでやった私には
この液のみを認識するだけでも
なんとなく機嫌がいいなということになっちゃいますからね
ほんの瞬間なんですけどね
で だからそれはちゃんと瞑想を通して
あれとパテヴィだけ認識するとすごい気持ちいい
次にパテヴィとを占領していた空間を認識するということ
それは難しいんだけど
まあなんとか理解できると思いますね
3番目に何やるかというと
この空間を認識していた自分の認識を取るんです
それで初めて外から対象が変わるんです
中へ  それも即席でちょっとちょっと説明できますよ
で 時々我々何か楽しいこと終わったりとかね
しちゃうと たまにこの誰かに会って話して楽しかったということはありますね
だからいつでもその人と話した言葉やら
その人の顔とかを思い浮かんで
一人勝手に楽しむということではなくて
時々何のことなくそれで楽しみのみ続く時もありますね
だから何かをしてみんな楽しんだりするでしょうに
で その楽しかったすぐなんですけど
まだ楽しいんですね その人は帰ったんだけどね
うん？まあホッとするよりも楽しいっていうね
そうやってこの出来事終わっても
あの快感というか刺激というか
その刺激だけ残っている時あります
要因が残ってるっていう
で だからもしその要因をきちっと捕まえておけば
いつまでも楽しきられます
だからご飯食べて 人と喋って
パーティーやって楽しかったという場合は
これものすごい珍しいことで
それを楽しむために毎回パーティーやらなくちゃいけないんだからね
ではなくて 今 1回そんなことをやって
すごく舞い上がって刺激になって
その感覚を維持すると
そうするともう二度とパーティーやる必要ないんで
その得る刺激 感覚 楽しみを続けることはできます
だからこれかなり難しいことなんですけど
我々の日常生活の中では
そのことは誰にでも経験あると思います
その楽しみの要因を で
もうちょっと楽しんじゃうというね
で あの 例えばまあそっちも怒ったり怒鳴ったりする人がいるとします
そこでその人には何かすごいいいことが起きたりしますね
いいこと言って その人すぐものすごく喜んじゃって
そこで家に帰っても その日は先生人に怒鳴ったりはしません
なんかすごい機嫌がいいと
それは要因なんですね
まあそんなようなものなんで
だからあのものはないんです
この場合は自分の内たるこの喜びをまた味わってるんですね
で あの それはもうあまり長持ちはしません
だから例えばそっちを怒るんだから
怒る原因また目の前に起こっちゃいますから
それまた認識しちゃうと
あの要因はそれで死んでしまっちゃうんですね
だからこのヴィンニャーナンチャーヤってのは
その機能のもう究極的なレベル高いのことなんですね
そこで空間を認識した
だから物質の世界ではそれ以上はもうありません
だから空間よりももっと何かっていうことは成り立ちませんだからね
そこで物質の世界 それで終了
次にその空間を認識した自分がいた
認識して その認識そのものを次に認識する
結局自分の心の状態ではないかと
外のことではなくて そこでその人はこの
の心にはこのパタヴィ・サンニャーもないし
空間というサンニャーもないし
認識だけのことやというね
だから認識は有象の結果なんですけど
結局認識だけのことやったところに留まってもらう
それが正しく如実に空証を実践していく方法やと
心を転倒すること 逆さまに物事を取ろうとしないでね
だってあの 色空である
色受想行全部だから空であると
無明からもう生老病死まで空であると
あの空 空体 空受滅度空である
堂々と言ってるでしょ
般若心経では お釈迦様が空受滅度を教えているのに
因果法則を教えているのに
それ仏道に逆らって仏道まで否定してない
それ転倒のいいところでしょうに
だから涅槃も空であると
輪廻もまあ空であると
そこでもう涅槃に入る人もいないと
故に 涅槃を得るという人もいないと
では明らかに転倒というかね
になって もう仏教はもうすごい綺麗さっぱり捨てるっていうかね
だからそれが空論とは言えませんね
空証とは言えませんね
それはもうブラフマン教で言っても
すべては絶対的な実体で我ですよというとこよりも
もうタチの悪い あの 実体論なんですね
だからこちらではっきりと言葉で
正しく如実に転倒しないで空証を取る方法っていうのはこういうものと
そこで次に で アーカーサという空間も認識しない
ヴィンヤーナンチャヤタナン
自分の認識そのものを認識しないことにする
アキンチャナンということ
じゃあ認識もなかったらどうなるんでしょうかと
認識もちょっとした一時的なものだからね
それ あれよりもものすごい難しいんです
アキンチャナンっていうのは
もう日本訳で言えば何もないというね
訳はどうなってます？え？無常
うん だから無常ということは
もう論理的には認識不可能っていうことなんです
でもこれで初めてできるようになるんですよ
ここまで心育ててみれば
だって空を取った人っていうのはすごい大胆なことをやってるんだからね
空間取っただけでね それからその空間取って喜び
その認識を取ったところ
それすごい難しい 大大変なことで
そこで認識にしたってあてにならんもんだからね
それも別段実体あるとかなんとかないんだけど
それ結局は何もないっていうところに
集中してみようとします
それでまたサマーディが生まれるんです
[沈黙]そこで その人にとってはものすごい心落ち着いています
何の煩わしいこともない
で もう山も人々から空き地とかそんなものもうとっくにはない
それで土だけですよと
それはもうない 空間だけですよと
それももうない 空間を感じた心ではないか
それはもうない そういう煩わしい状態はもう今は存在しない
でも一つ認識しています
無我ということをね だから無常を今初めて認識してるんですよ
でもそれ認識ですよ だから無常を確実に認識したところで
それも有常なんです ということなんです
だから この人はもう確実に無常
もう認識が取ってしまえばもう何もないんだからね
それに集中してるんです
だからそれを性として概念として取ってますから
一切何もないと 無常だと
無常だと認識しているんだから
その無常やというちょっとした煩わしさがまだあるんです
認識だから これも で 次に色も認識しないで
いわゆる認識さえも認識しないで
それから阿闍梨ちゃんが何もないということを認識しないで
最後にネーヴァサンニャーナーサンニャーという
この認識するそのものを
あるひそひいひそという風な訳だと思いますけどね
それでそれは何もないというサマーディからはそれほど難しくはないんです
だからこの順番でもね
難しいって難しくないというところありますよ
あの土を見ていて 土を取って空間認識することはすごいこの段階で
もう成功するかしないかわからない
ものすごい壁なんです
そこで一旦空間認識した人にとっては
次にそれほど難しくないんですよ
自分のこの要因をね 認識そのものをね
集中することはもうそれほど難しくないんです
で 要因認識を認識した人にとって
次に残っているのは この認識を取ってしまって何もないという無常を認識することなんですね
そこはまた壁があるんですよ
で 無常を認識しちゃうと
もう本当にすごい難しいんですよ
認識なんですけど 何認識しているかっていうことはないんだから
次にもう最後 これ以上心集中することは無理
不可能 ひそひそひそという
どういうことでしょうかね
それでこの今認識しているでしょ？きちんと空というもの
無というものね 無と言った方がいいんですね
こう言えば無ということになる
次に無だからね もう認識するということは何たることをかと
これも認識しないことにするんです
認識しないだけって 他のものを認識しようともしない
無 無常やと全てという風になっていたところで
だから無常だから なんで認識する必要あるかっていうことで
その認識をしない方に努力するんです
これかなり壁なんです
で 無常と認識する それは認識です
ですから無常という有常なんですね
結局 それで でもその人はすごい進んでる人だから
無常ですから そんなにわざわざ認識するということはありえないんですね
それでまあ自然的にもなりますけど
どんどん別に認識するものはないということで
心がすごく機能はものすごく薄くなっちゃうんですね
こちらバカでかい像がいると
いとも簡単に認識するでしょうに
そんな風に像がどんどん小さくなって消えて消えて原子一個になってくると
もう認識することはなくなっちゃいますね
そんな感じで もう認識する主体対象が空でしたから
すぐに認識するその機能がすごく我々の立場から言えばすごく弱くなるんです
でも 瞑想の立場から見ればすっごく強くなるんです
この強くなるんだけど
何も認識していない だからそう認識があるかないかどちらかというところになるので
それ以上は進めません
そこでこの山がある 壁があると認識するともう有象の世界だから
この人にとっては最終的には私は認識しているかいないかということもないという状態まで心は成長するします
サンニャーがあるともないとも言えない状態
だからそこではっきりと空照が成り立っています
有象だったら必ずサンニャーが生まれる
今はサンニャーがあるかないかどちらかなという曖昧な状態でですから
もうもう九十パーセント以上もう空照の世界なんです
そこでありとあられるところから
今はシュンニャーになったということは知っています
空性になったとは知っています
でも えーと このサンニャーね
この片片のこの小さなね
このサンニャー ちょっとなんかサンニャーらしくはないんですよ
山とかね そんな感覚じゃないんだけど
何もないこと それはサンニャーとも言えないところまで行ってるんだからね
その分でも存在しているんだからね
そろそろ有象なんですね
だからそこまでそれ以上薄くすることはできません
だから禅定の世界で それは最頂点ですよ
この非想非想処定 またワンステップあります
［外国語］次に あのアーカサーナンで空間を認識しないし
あの ではなくて アキンチャイタに何もない無想も認識しないし
あのヒーソーヒーヒーソーというね
認識あるかないかというその感覚も認識しない
アニミッタンテ チェトー サマディン パティッチェ マニシカロティ
そこでアニミッタン 何も想がない
いわゆる何も認識しない
いわゆる形を取らない心で情報を取らない心で
情報を取らないでサマーディが作れないかと
今まで情報を取ってサマーディを作ってきたんです
多層の情報を捨てて 一つの情報と
それでどんどんどんどん進んでいくんですね
で 進んでいって まあ物理的に言えば
我々は手で何かするとものすごい大量なもので
指で取っちゃうとほんの少々取れる
何か道具で取っちゃうとほんの少々取れると
それでどんどん進んでいって
あの ナノの世界で原子の単位で取ると
でもその人はかなり進んでないと技術的にはそれはできません
次に もうステップ進んでみると
いわゆるこの何も認識しないことでサマーディ状態が作れるかというアニミッタ・サマーディと呼んで
それに ニミッタがない
特色がないサマーディ
それにチャレンジする
そこでサマーディが生まれる
で読んでみますけど ヤッサース・ダラタ・アーキンチャーヤタナ・サマー・サンニャン・パティッチ・テーダ・ナッティ
何もないというサマーディから生まれた煩わしいところもない
イエーア・スダラタ・ネーワ・サンニャーナ・サンニャーヤタナ・サンニャン・パティッチ
ヒーソー・ヒーソーという認識概念から生まれた煩わしさもない
アッティッチ・エーワ・アヤン・ダラタ・マッタ・ヤリダン・イマン・エーワ・カーヤン・パティッチ・サラーヤタ・サラーヤタニカン・ジーヴィティ・パッチャ
でも一つまだ残っています
イム・エーワ・カーヤン・パティッチ
その まだ体があるんだから
こちらにね その体にまだ六処ありますね
ゲン・イーディ・シッシン・イーというね
認識はしてないんだけど
機械持ってます 目で何も見てないんだけど
目は持ってます 耳で何も聞いてないんだけど
耳持ってます 耳っていうのはこういう物理的な耳というよりも
この六処だから その認識機能持ってますね
認識機能持ってます 認識はしてない
でもそれでも煩わしいんですよ
例えば音楽は聴きたくない
面倒くさいんだから うるさい
全然聞きませんと言っても
その人の家でイスティリはあるかもしれませんね
でもイスティリがあるということ自体もちょっとした迷惑ということなんですよ
もう聞いてはないんですよ
だから楽なんです 音楽は嫌いし
もう嫌でうるさくてたまらないと
で 前はもうもうロックやら何でも聞きたくてイスティリはあったと
それでこれうるさいんだからといって
どんどんどんどん歌謡曲になったり
いろいろ変わっていって
クラシックになったりして
もうこれもうるさいということで
まあなんとか変な動きもありますね
なんとか音楽という この何でしたっけ
え？え？ヒーリングのヒーリング系のね
安らぎ系の音楽ってえっらい安らぎじゃないんです
あれは 私はこのロックなんか聞いちゃうと
まあすごく落ち着いていますけど
聞かなきゃいいんだからね
だから別にボンボンと音が出たってもね
で 聞いてやろうかなと思ったら
まあ全部単純でしょうしね
いいんですけど あれ安らぎ系聞いちゃうとえらくイライラするんですね
なぜ時々音があったりなかったり
それ気にするんですよ
何これと 突然全くこの不自然というか
この法則と違ってね あの
何か音が突然入ったりとかね
あれほどイライラする音楽っていうのはないんだから聞きません
とにかく置いておいて
そこでクラシック聞いて
それから安らぎ系の音楽に聞いて
まあこれもやめましょうということで
その人は全く音楽は聞かないことにする
それでも一つまだ煩わしいことはイスティリはあるということで
そこでその修行者はもう今私にとってはもう何も存在しませんですけど
すべてシュンヤですよと
でも ただまだこのイスティリを持ってるんだと
そこら辺ではまだシュンヤではありませんと
このイスティリはジーヴィティ・パッチイカということで
この生きているんだから
この細胞やらそのものは存続しちゃうでしょ
だからもうもう自分の意思と関係なく
もう 生き続けちゃいますから
例えば我々人間の体を作っちゃうと
餌さえあげればもう六年
八十年ぐらいはもうとにかくもう続けちゃうんですね
この体がゴキブリぐらいにしてみれば
まあわかりません 寿命はわかりませんだけど
まあまあ おそらくね 一年
二年か三年 三ヶ月はわかります
それぐらいは持ちますね
とにかく これはジーヴィタ・パッチャということなんですね
だから空いてるこの機会によって
もうやっぱり続けちゃうんですよ
そこで何か栄養をあげなきゃ
人間の場合は二週間ほどでもう消えてしまうしね
他の動物の体だったら
もう時々ね  1年でも餌が何もなくても大丈夫と
もう魚もすごいね 生命力あるみたいですね
すごい冬とか寒い時はもう餌も何も食べないでじーっといる
体は大きくならないんですね
だけど 暖かくしてあげると
パクパクと食べて 体どんどんと大きくなっちゃうと
だからこの体の大きさってのはすごい簡単に管理できる
だからこの養殖する場合でもね
で そうするみたいんですね
だから海から取れる時はもう魚を大きくさせません
小さいまんまで置いておいて
そこでもう海から取れない時に計算して
それで餌を 水の温度を上げて餌をあげて大きくしてもらうというのをやってますからね
だからそんな簡単に死なないみたいですね
魚の寿命ってのはほとんどわからないんだからね
私は年取った死んだ魚っていうのは 1匹しか知りません
自分のお寺でいた魚なんですけどね
まああれ 不細工な魚でしたけど
すごいもう仲良く遊んでくれるわね
すごい悲しかったんです
あの魚死んで で なんかもう何十年いたかわからないんです
いっそお寺に持ってきたことを小さい時から知ってるんだから
私も そこでものすごくふざけて遊ぶわ
もうすごい楽しいんです
もう この間行ったらもう全部しわが出ていて
鼻の方とかね で 私が怒ったんで
お前ら餌あげてないんではないかとかね
であげたって食べないしね
で まあ水も入れ替えて
汁水って とにかくみんな遊んであげないんだから
機嫌が悪くなってるんだろうとね
寂しがってるんだよと思って遊びに呼んだんですね
出てこない それで次の日も行って呼んだ
呼びましたけど もう出てこない
中に入って もうそのまま死んじゃったんですね
だから まあしょうがなくて
まあちゃんとまあ埋葬してあげましたけどね
すごい丁寧に だからずっと一緒に生活していて
もうなんかもう本当に不思議ですよ
だからみんな不思議だったんです
だから気持ちわかることやらね
もうふざけることやらきりがない
だから魚はもう顔の方で年は見えましたけどね
なんかしわみたいになってるからね
ハートかはもう大体落ちませんだから魚の場合
いつでも歯はすごい元気
ものすごい鋭い歯が持っていたんです
人間の指ばっか食って食って
あれで強くなったかわかりませんだけど
もう私の手なんかもうか
噛みたい放題 もう噛むんです
でも噛むんだけど この怪我させないように気をつけるところびっくりなんですね
すると飛んで泳いできてパクッと噛むんですね
噛んでしっぽ振って逃げますから
だって怪我しますよ でも怪我させないで
ちゃんと この あれは不思議でしたからね
一番嫌がるのは尻尾を掴まえること
それはまあ尻尾を掴まっちゃう
えらく怒るんで その時はもう必ず噛まれる
やっぱり魚ってどれぐらい年取るかわかりませんね
とにかく まあそれぞれ体によってはね
まあそういう そういう物質的な法則は一応ありますね
まあ人間だったらもう何も栄養あげない場合はね
まあそんな 2週か 2週持てるっていうことはないんですね
中の栄養取ったところでね
自己破壊の細胞を壊して栄養取っちゃいますからね
そういう原理主義がありますね
そういうことでも何も認識しないんだから大変楽なんですけど
まだこの六根入ってる意識を持っていると
で まあそれからこれはアニミッタサマーディということ
このアニミッタサマーディっていうのは
あのー サマーディ瞑想とちょっと関係ないんです
今まで説明したサマーディ瞑想でアニミッタサマーディっていうのはヴィパッサナー瞑想の世界なんです
無常というか ニッッタ
常ですから無常サマーディというね
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想してもアニミッタサマーディというのは生まれてきます
アニミッタサマーディと同時に悟り開けます
ね だからネーワサンニャー
ナーサンニャーってのまで普通のサマーディの世界
それは仏教だけではなくて
お釈迦様もいろいろ先生二人から教えていただいたもので
それ以上心が成長しませんということで
まあまあそれはお釈迦様は分かりました
やっぱりそれではできませんと
でもこれで悟りがないんだと
まだあの有の世界ということでね
そこでまあ次に取り扱われているのはアニミッタサマーディというね
で アニミッタサマーディはどのように取るかというと
やっぱりこのものの無常を見るんですね
滅を見るんです 生と滅の中
だからものを認識しない
現象を認識しない まずは現象を認識する
痛みとか膨らみとかね
縮みとかしびれとか あるものを認識するんですよ
それでやがてこれ やって
やって やって やって やって
ものすごくもうできるようになってくると
あらこれ痛みって 次にこれ
次にこれ 次にこれっていうことで
意識がこの この滅見入っちゃうんですね
消えるんだ 消えるんだと
滅ばっかし見ようと思ったって
それはできません だからこのラベリングするというか
ものすごい大量にラベリングラベリング入っていると
もうものすごいラベリングで
今痛みとラベリングした人が次に別なものにラベリングしているでしょうし
それサマーディが出てくると
もうたくさんもの出てこないで一つだけになっちゃうんです
例えば膨らみだったら膨らみ縮みだけになっちゃう
他のものはわからなくなっちゃうんです
まるっきりないことになっちゃうんです
ただ膨らみ縮みだけ それでも膨らみ見たってもいろいろがあって
縮みだってもいろいろあって
結構もうラベリングの方はすっごく変わるっていうこと
ただラベリング変わったっていうことは
現象が変わったっていうことなんですね
膨らみとラベリングしていたものが縮みとラベリングすると膨らみがないと
消えたっていうことなんです
そこをやっていると なんとなくこの滅の方向へ心が行くんですね
だからそれはこの寄り道で起こるものなんですよ
寄り道というじゃないな
まあ横道で起こるものなんです
わざと取ろうっていうことは
それは無理です 一応現象の道で行くんですね
するとそこら辺で発見するんですね
で この滅を見ると また生が見えてきて
また滅が見えてきて まあそこで瞬間
心を何も取らんことにしてしまっちゃうんです
それがアニミッタサマーディなんですよ
だからヴィパッサナーだけでもそこら辺には行けます
サマーディからは結構道が長いんだけど
ヒースのこのヒースーヒーヒースージョーから残り
それでいったら残るのはアニミッタサマーディしか残ってないんです
そこで次にこの人はこのアニミッタサマーディに入ってから
アニミッタサマーディにチッタムパックアンニワサンティムッチャティ
ソエワンパジャナティ
アヤンプティコアニミットトチェトーサマーディ
アビサンカトアビサンチェイと
アニミットを見ようではないか
無常を見ようではないかと私は思ってこのサマーディを作ったんではない
だからそちらにもチェタナーというかね
意識で働いたんだろうと
ヤンコウパナキンチアビサンカタンアビサンチェイタイタン
わざと考えて作ったならば
それはサンカーラなんですね
アビサン だからまあちょっと違うみたいだ
こちらでお釈迦様はサマーディの世界から生まれるアニミットサマーディのことをおっしゃってるんですね
わざと強引にアニミットを取っちゃうんだと
わざと強引に滅を取って瞑想すると悟りではないんですよ
だからこの場合 それ言ってるみたいですね
だから今私はこのアニミットにサマーディ作ったんだけど
それも私はわざわざとやったものではないか
作ったものではないか
ですから作られたものをね
考えたものはただニッチャン
そんなものはアニッチャン
無常である ニローダダンマ
消えると 最終的に空のギリギリのところに行って
もう何も取らないというところになったら
それも強引にやったんだからね
だからそれも無常であると
それさえ だから空性についても無常っていうことにするんです
ニローダダンマと知るんだと
タッサエワンジャナトイワンパサトカーマアサピチッタン
それで初めて欲から心がきれいになる
欲が落ちる ババアサグ
存在したいというそこからも心がきれいになって
存在したいという気持ちも落ちてしまう
アヴィッジャアサグ 無明というものも落ちてくる
それで落ちたと 心にいろいろ物っていうのはね
イムッタスミンディ 落ちたっていうことは知るんですね
心はもう落ちたと 全部
それすぐ実感で生まれるんだ
終わったという実感 すぐ生まれるんですね
それでキーナジャーティウサンパハッチャラン
それで修行終わりますよと
正夢終わりますよ カタンカラニヤン
為すべきことは成し得たと
ナアパラングイッタイタ
これ以上やることはないとわかりますと
ソイワンパジャナティ
ヤンアスダレタカーマアスワンパキッチ
欲という煩悩から出てきた疲れがあったらそれはない
何かこのババアサグ 存在に対する欲があったならば
そこから何か 苦しみが生まれる
それももうない それからアヴィッジャ
無明から出てくる 無明っていうのは認識することで有象を認識すること自体無明なんですよ
だからそこから出てきた苦しみはもうないと
アッティ チェーワヤン ダラダ マッタ
まあちょっとした疲れがありますよと
それは何なのかというと
イマミーワ カヤン パティッチョ
この体に対してはまだまだちょっと疲れが残っていると
サラーヤ ティニカン 六 showがあるんだからね
そこら辺はちょっとまだまだちょっとめんどくさいと
それだけですよと 体 機械
リステリを残っているというリステリを処分すればそれで簡単にですからね
全く要らないんだったらね
置いておく必要ないでしょうしね
ジーヴィティ パッチャ
生きてるんでところちょっと残ってるんだけど
ソ スンニャン イダン サンニャーガタン
そこで自分のサンニャーガタン
自分の認識は これからはまるっきりこのカーマーセーワ
バーワーセーワ アヴィッジャーセーワというものからスンヤであると
もうないとわかっているんですね
アッティ チェー イダン アスンニャ
アスンニャというほんのちょっとあります
イダン 体というものだけはちょっとまだまだアスンニャですよと
非空性ですよと  それでスンニャターの実践は終わりますね
パリッスッダ パラマ アヌッタラ
これは最高なスンニャの実践だと
これ以上ものはないんだと
スンニャター ワッカン
だから心から煩悩がすべて落ちるところまで
まあ実践するんです 実際の煩悩落ちて解脱したら
もうそれでそれこそスンニャターなんです
それでも認識のところで論理的に語るんです
だからそれでも心体があるんだから
そこら辺はもう一時的にあるとは言ってます
ある意味では体壊れるのは当たり前のことだからね
死ぬっていうことは それは別にもうどうったことはない
ただ体壊れるまで待っていればいいんです
イェーヒ
ケーチー アナンダ アティティ マッダーナーン サマナーワー ブラーフマナー パリシッダーン パラマ アヌッタラ
ーン スンニャターン ウパサンパッジャ ヴィーハレンス
サッビーテー イマン イヨ パリシッダーン パラマ アヌッタラーン スンニャターン ウパサンパッジャ ヴィーハレンス
過去生でいたシャモンバラモンたちが
もし最高に清らかな最高たるスンニャター
空性を体験して実践したというならば
この方法ですよ それから
将来で誰かが空性を体験するそうと言うんだったら
それもこの方法でしかできません
なので 今現在にしても
誰かが空性を体験したいと思うならば
この方法しかないんだよということで
厳密に言ってしまうんです
だからこれはもう徹底的に
絶対的な もうこれしかない
だからものすごい厳密にこの論じるのはそういうわけなんです
徹底的に科学的っていうのはそういうわけなんです
科学的だから 過去であろうが現在でも将来であろうが
もう方法同じだからね
だから他の方法あるんだったら
もう誰が言ったってもいいんだけど
他のチャレンジあるんだったら言ってみなさい
いろいろ言うかもしれません
それは理解が足らないんだから言うだけやって
理解した人っていうのはこれ以上はないってこと知ってるんです
タスマーティ アナンダ パリシッダーン パラマ アヌッタラーン スンニャターン
パリシッダーン 清らかである
パラマ アヌッタラーン
すべてのものを乗り越えている
スンニャターン スンニャター
空性をウパサンパッジャ
空性に入ってヴィーヒリッサマ
生活しましょうと エーワン ヒウワーナンダ シッティッタ
頑張りなさい だからきちんとやり方を説明しているんだからね
頑張れるでしょうに すごい丁寧に空性を体験する教えをしているんです
だから生きている上ではね
空性っていうのは じゃあ空性を認識してやるぞと
これは成り立たないんです
認識するものは有性なんですね
全て悟り開いたっていうのも
体からくる機会があるんだっていうことがあるので
その点では有なんですよ
認識としてはね だから仏教の空性っていうのは
世界は有か無かとか そんなもういい加減な形而上学的な話ではないんですね
だからすごい認識論学的に
だから こちらに川があるかないかっていうことは
我々は認識することによって成り立つんであって
川ですよという人間はそういうふうに認識する
魚は川ですよとは認識しないでしょうに
だから実際に客観的に川が存在するかと論じていいんでしょうかね
人間だけは川やと論ずるかもしれませんだけど
魚にとっては別に別な話なんですね
だから世は空か無そうではないかという話ではありません
それはあくまでも認識の話で
この絵は綺麗かないかと
絵についていちいち語るんじゃなくて
自分にとっては綺麗に見えるかないかということなんですよ
たとえ高価な絵であろうとも
自分にとってはつまらないと認識しちゃうと
自分にとってはつまらないんですね
それは だから真理は認識に当てはめて語らなくてはいけないんです
だから認識の世界で空性は成り立つんだよと
空性がなかったならばすごい苦しいんだよと
山もある 谷もある 町もある
田舎もあると思っちゃうと
その分心は苦しみますね
だからもう空性を認識にするということ
だから世の中にとってはもう関係ない
我々仏教には興味もない
これ形而上学的な そこで徹底した実践論と認識論で仏教というのは終了いたしますので
この辺で話を終了します
いやー難しいですが